salut c'est monsieur groupe d'ici
quelques jours je vais partir à madrid
avec schumi pour vous présenter des tout
nouveaux modèles
je ne sais pas tout de suite quels
seront les marques si on me gardent le
secret dire le suspense et n'en dit pas
trop j'ai omis vous le savez se
développe énormément est arrivé en
france est pas très longtemps avec plein
de nouveaux modèles et ils vont
continuer à se développer en europe et
ça c'est super intéressant donc a priori
ces produits pourraient être le mieux à
deux et le mit à 2 light peut-être on
prend des pincettes mais tous pensent à
le croire donc ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on m'a parlé du miel du miel de light
on va parler du voyage à madrid parce
que je vous emmène avec moi alors pas
directement pratiquement mais
indirectement vous expliquera tout de
suite on regarde
j'aime bien chiant je trouve qu'ils ont
des produits plutôt sympa que ce soit
dans l'entrée de gamme dans milieu de
gamme ou dans le haut de gamme sont
vraiment un éventail qui est extrêmement
large une gamme qui est très complète et
puis des produits qui tiennent la route
c'est cool vous ai parlé ya pas très
longtemps 2006 de sg vous parlez dans
pas longtemps 10,6 à rester connectés ou
ailleurs il ya plein de choses cool donc
vous invite à vous abonner
d'ici quelques jours on part à madrid
pour aller voir des nouveaux produits
des chocs
j'ai eu la chance d'être invité par la
marque pour aller découvrir ses nouveaux
produits chez omis annoncé sur son
compte twitter global launch
c'est-à-dire un lancement global
donc il devrait y avoir plusieurs
produits les fuites font état d'un
millier de et d'un billet de l'aïe qui
sera en tout cas le successeur du mit à
un lien qui est un produit de milieu de
gamme qui a vraiment cartonné sous
android one ces deux produits devraient
également être sous android one
donc c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
bien qu'elle n'ait eu chez omi a
confirmé qu'ils allaient bien danser le
mia de et le milieu de light le 24
juillet prochain à madrid
donc c'est plutôt une très très bonne
nouvelle comme quoi les rumeurs avaient
raison donc je confirme qu'on va aller
les découvrir les prendre en main et ça
c'est plutôt génial forcément entre le
moment où j'ai tourné la vidéo c'est à
dire hier et moment où je en train de la
moutte aujourd'hui la formation à tomber
donc petit décalage d'où la maquilleuse
allait reprendre pour l'épisode normal
city lancement global dit d'autres
produits peut-être que deux peut-être
d'autres ce sera un petit peu une
surprise donc ça plutôt content que ce
que je vais vous emmener avec moi on va
aller voir un peu ce qui se passe
peut-être shiomi pour ce lancement du 24
juillet et puis on va le faire un petit
tour de madrid
donc je vais vous emmener avec moi donc
on pourrait ça pas mal de choses si ça
vous intéresse à madrid certains d'entre
vous me réclamait une faq pourquoi pas
ça pourrait être cool d'ailleurs si
bouygues ont facilement vaincu marque mg
à toutes vos questions en bas en
commentaire comme ça répondre à quelques
questions si vous en avez et si vous
voulez que j'aille voir des choses en
particulier à madrid marqué le mois
également en commentaire comme ça je
m'organiserai un petit peu je voudrais
avoir du temps libre
ça permettra d'aller faire un tour de la
ville de vous montrer ce que vous voulez
voir madrid comme j'ai déjà eu la chance
d'y aller la ville est superbe c'est une
ville qui vit énormément elle est
géniale de france meilleur plein de
points contre épaule choses à raconter
on a vraiment c'est un plaisir dont je
vais vous emmener avec moi au travers de
la caméra pour parler maintenant du mit
à 2
millet de light à quelques infos plus
futés qui dresse en tout cas le portrait
robot de ce que pourrait être ses
produits pour un bien dont on devrait
avoir un écran de 5,99 pouces et une
résolution de 2160 par 1080 pixels fhd
plus une dalle ips lcd
le processeur sadr est un qualcomm
snapdragon 660 cadencé au maximum à 2,2
gigahertz 4 gigas de ram 64 giga de
stockage soit 128 giga du stockage
probablement les deux en option en
fonction du modèle choisi
on devrait avoir un double module caméra
à l'arrière d'un méga pixels et 12
mégapixels de 12 mégapixels ouvrant à f
1.75 et à l'avant un module de 20
mégapixels de l'usb type c'est un port
jack du bluetooth 5.0 est une batterie
aussi aux alentours des 3000
milliampères heures voilà un peu pour le
portrait de semis à deux et on devrait
avoir un miel de light pour ce biais de
laquelle on devrait avoir un écran de
5,84 pouces ratio 19/9 également un
écran lcd avec une résolution qhd plus
ils vont être équipés d'un qualcomm
snapdragon 625 4 gigas de ram 64 giga de
stockage en double module photo
l'arrière 12 mégapixels et 5 mégapixels
et un module 5 mégapixels à l'avant
la rumeur fait état d'une batterie de 4
millions terreur ça peut paraître un peu
bizarre d'avoir une batterie 4000
millions pérore sur le modèle light et
une batterie 3 millions en paire eur /
le modèle classique
bon ça on prend toujours avec des
pincettes on parle beaucoup de sueur
mais parce que comme je voulais déjà dit
dans plusieurs vidéos où la marque est
arrivé ya pas très longtemps en france
il ya plein de choses à dire on fait une
vraie découverte
on pouvait avoir avancé produit par des
importateurs comme guerbet est là
maintenant on peut les avoir directement
il ya un sav qui est géré directement
par schumi en f1 sont plutôt des bonnes
nouvelles donc on se penche beaucoup
dessus en ce moment pour découvrir un
peu la gamme
en tout cas ça c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous avez déjà des
produits de schumi est ce que vous
pourriez en acheter est-ce que ce mix de
s good boy vous invite d'ailleurs à les
découvrir la vidéo parce que moi j'ai
trouvé vraiment super est-ce que vous
avez déjà essayé de le premier tome i
est ce que vous en achetez ce que vous
avez vu par le passé est ce que vous en
avez actuellement vous marque 200
commentaires ailleurs beaucoup de choses
dans les commentaires entre la faq entre
madrid entre le fait de parler de chimie
alors beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
messages vous invite d'ailleurs à
répondre aux messages des autres permet
de nourrir tous appuyé moi j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps si déjà à les lire
et à vous répondre merci beaucoup d'être
toujours plus nombreux toujours plus
nombreux en route pour les cent mille
abonnés d'ici la fin de l'année mercato
capitaux de rendez vous très très très
rapidement à madrid vous allez voir ça
va être super cool et d'ici là vous
vendra soyez sages ciao
[Musique]